what's the matter I just am i right man
I'm just look a little shook up now not
a lot gets to you man yeah I just
thought we had it this year what I
thought we had it this year I I know
we're gonna be back next year though
we're gonna be back stronger gonna learn
from this defeat so I'll let you tell me
your breathe no man I'm not talking
about my braces Brennan you know I I
thought you had it this year too with
your braces but no I'm not talking about
my braces no you mean getting better at
social media well it's the boys in blue
man the LAPD no I'm talking about the
Tim what I'm talking about the Dodgers
thing you know they gave it the old try
though I we were we're gonna get him
next year and the tiers gonna come later
it's not gonna come now cuz we're gonna
do a show and I know that I know that
they would want me to pull this show off
the way it needs to be pulled off and
and this one today is for the Dodger
fans it's for all you for the boys to
bleed blue you bleed blue and so do I
how boring is that game [ __ ] right I
thought that just used to rent all this
is game 7 5 nothing enjoy your time for
the next 8 anything's well nothing
happened I heard a woman on the radio it
was so great cuz she was just like she
was so sweet she was older and she goes
I just want him to know she was talking
about the manager that we love him he
[ __ ] that we love him and then we
think he's you know that we know it's
gonna be coming back yeah it's bad
she was crying I was like [ __ ] there's
some real fan Jojo and her mama the
biggest Dodgers fan and everyone is
kicking off I'd stand up go
hashtag Houston strong non-stop non-stop
Houston strong I do take you I get it
takes from you it's annoying I get it
takes broheim people for the Dodgers
game game seven it's actually really fun
you're a dead sis
nice reply back [ __ ] you how about
yesterday when I'm on the phone with you
and I'm talking about this place that I
eat I think I was like oh you should try
it I got out of a meeting I was trying
to order food you're like dude you know
there's nothing worse I know you got to
do this Russia it's off seven and a half
do you go there you go on I went oh yeah
is it clear yeah I go I go it's called
Mon petit Poulet here you go oh yeah
what is that
it's called Mon petit Poulet clinic I'm
like well where's that yes all you do it
quick there's nothing like a good hang
up there's nothing bad good [ __ ] hang
up on some feels good yeah it feels real
good my buddy Jerry used to that he used
to have a habit you be talking if you
got it man he go ah yeah just click you
just scream I'll tell what the Dodgers
did do Dodgers put a damper on the
Comedy Store all shows even The Improv
oh sure just serious yeah that's yeah
huh nuts not empty but you know the
coffee stores is always sold out its
first time in sold out no I don't know
how long so as I let I had a 11:00
should I went on at 11:40 Lim forty
money on the [ __ ] Houston Astros
because this is how I look at sports
sometimes I got on a [ __ ] about now
follow baseball but I felt like I'd
watched every game and I felt like
because of the flood and the storm that
Houston suffered I think athletes
sometimes it can get into the thing
where destiny is on their side and
they're gonna win however oh do you have
our do you after or is it the Dodgers up
the highest payroll don't give a [ __ ]
about Houston struggles and the just a
better team won well the better it's not
like they pulled it out no it's all just
played awful yeah that had nothing to do
with anything that's alright sometimes I
feel like destiny like as an athlete
you're like Destiny's on my side I'm you
know you just feel like that's one way
to think about the Dodgers don't you
know they're not like it's their destiny
well when the Yankees when the Yankees
play Grieg is like I'm in paid a hundred
million I'm gonna try and knock this
[ __ ] ball at the park under who cares
about Houston professional sports don't
work like that no no you're not
sentimental that way the other team
doesn't care right not like let's give
this one to Houston no that's not what I
mean no I know you Houston's like let's
rally around yeah if you like they're
playing for something bigger that's a
really really good team they're really
yeah really good from the the bound of
baseball I've watched which is not
terribly minimal because my dad such a
fan they hit they I've never seen that
many players hit that many [ __ ] I hit
that well it's crazy yeah I don't know
but I'm mean you told him baseball's
weird yeah but um
[Music]
comic store debt like dad and I was like
I was thinking like God ain't you know
I'm just used to always being packed so
I get that it's late I'm using bad whose
days are usually in bed by 9:30 he's in
bed by 9:30 so I Drive the comic store I
leave there like 10:45 and I get there
and I go to the house in the belly room
go the main room it's you know it's gay
and I see the the guy who's running it
what's the name Erik Adam Adam yeah any
unlike Game seven he's like right god
damn it so people are doing a thing in
there I'm in the bedroom upstairs and
there's like a bunch of newer comics
were only doing five minutes and I was
gonna close the show yeah so I go up
there I mean don't get me wrong I'm
blessed are we doing anything if comi
stores my favorite place on the goddamn
planet I'm don't I don't take you for
granted
so I go up then I go in the back of the
green room on a psychotic that's gonna
be a late night there's 14 people in the
crowd if that you know like here we go
and then Dave Chappelle walks in sits
down next to me I talked them for about
30 minutes
Wow going back and forth about comedy
and lady around the show goes hey Dave
do you want going before after
perennials no no he's the closer man
yeah you know what what do you want and
I'm like what what do you mean he's like
should you want me go I go you know I'll
introduce you heck yeah man you close
this [ __ ] out yeah he's like for sure
that's what you do so timeout fighting
all that stuff and then I go on it goes
well I introduced bring up Dave
Chappelle and then I in the belly room
in the belly room when I sat front row
watch Dave set do I'm talking cackling I
was bent over everyone I mean he you
don't he just shut the place down back
and even with Davis means they were
talking about fighting in boxing you
recognize your yeah we're talking about
boxing for a while yeah and he go I go
man it's weird this place is never like
this I became seventy is he this is this
what you want brother this way you work
he's like the if you're not gonna be
able to deal with momentum they're where
they feel pressure to laugh like here's
I figure out what's gonna be funny here
that's right oh my god no I got pipe I
was like five oh yeah if it worship hell
yeah drop in knowledge right now I went
up there like a [ __ ] banshee then
brought Dave up and I'm Dave and it he
must he was just doing some new material
everybody's doing but it was about all
the Hollywood stuff and brave dude I'm
telling you it was brilliant it was so
funny man Wow yeah man if you can if
I've always said if it works at the
Comedy Store to work anywhere in the
country it's an amazing place to work
I'd like to have seen that I just seen
Dave's commentary on it's just it's just
great it's just crazy going you know
you're the comments tour I'm like ah man
14 people what are we gonna do and then
Dave walked in the back like yeah that's
the Comedy Store man it's good times for
comedy man because all this insanity
good times for comedy and for lawyers
yeah bad time for males bad time for men
that time for somebody Christine ever
said that heterosexual sex is being
policed the way because even like
groping or just like a sexual
advancement you've made an advance at me
it's being policed the way gay men were
police in the 70s 80s and that 60 70s
Navy well I feel like you're wearing
those outs this wit like bunch people
we've said this where they go it's a
witch hunt on man I go slow your roll
it's a witch on it's different than the
Salem witch hunts because these guys are
actual witches like it's a you're an
actual some of the guys some have
complete peace name someone that came
out who is it yeah well no I think
sometimes I think in in like name but
name a big name where you're like no
that's not true no but I think it's
angels in some cases there are certain
actors or certain people whoever they
might be who that the environment is
actually such that when one person makes
an accusation you can lose your
livelihood what about well now I you got
to be proven innocent right you're
guilty and guilty right way too and by
the way backwards not even when and and
this this includes like just he made a
nun he made me feel uncomfortable he
made me he made advances he made lewd
jokes he touched my butt now you know
those things those things might have
made you uncomfortable my question is
does that number one you don't get your
name back you don't get proven innocent
you don't I don't care what happens it's
on you it's on you it's on it's it lives
on the Internet depends who you are
though for the most part of the chemo
people do in
you know in this marketplace it seems to
me that people are on the verge of
losing everything based on somebody's
accusation there are cases like that but
depends on the defense me but my only
argument to that is the the guys that
they're doing after like I said it's a
witch hunt
of real witches they don't there's not a
lot of cases we're like no no let's take
it easy like the Kevin Spacey stuff the
reason you know it's true is he's like
uh if that did happen like they're not
they're not going no no [ __ ] you I never
did that bring it on right lawyer up
[ __ ] he's going I need help and then 40
other people come out yeah now used to
have the title of the ultimate dick
diver kevin spacey the ultimate dick
diver yeah have you seen someone's I
mean just grabbing dicks laughs yeah
he's he's he was a gay man who was in
the theater in the world and probably
put up a lot of numbers I know my friend
was gay had a thing with him so you know
that I I don't I don't know what goes on
there I don't know the guy and I've
never I don't know that whole world
really but I'm sure there was a lot of
[ __ ] going on I'm sure but you can't
be a predator yeah I don't know I don't
know Kevin Spacey I don't know you know
I don't know Netflix is screwed oh I'd
say Netflix like we're all set yeah and
then house cards see ya and then he's
like I need help how about when Kevin
Spacey when the dick and all that the
salt came out he's like yeah my bad I'm
gay like all right he did not help man
he did not handle that well at all he
was like maybe that did happen that's 40
years years ago I don't remember table
Dave oh yeah we're like well well it's
cool that put that to the side what
about this well we're 20 when you say 14
like I had this [ __ ] knockout drag-out
fight about I was with all these older
actors and they were defending Roman
Polanski because he wanted to come back
in the country okay and he wanted to
escape prosecution Roman Polanski Roman
Polanski was a was a was a concentration
camp survivor and he was also a very
well known director and married to
Shannon Tate Sharon Tate who was killed
by Manson in his group
okay she was she was say eight months
pregnant they stabbed her 50 times Oh
some terrible things but having said all
that and Roman Polanski a hell of a
director directed didn't need any direct
was at the
look up look up no but look up what he
directed I've seen several of his movies
but but amazing but but here was my
thing
they wanted to have him come back to the
United States and kind of forget this
thing like Hollywood supports him and so
he rounded China
well it's the piano wait Rosemary's Baby
groundbreaking Chinatown the theme one
movie you study in film school is
Chinatown it is at the top of the film
canon one of the greatest movies ever
made
okay one of the greatest movies ever
melt brother maybe the Odyssey won an
Oscar yes and they gave him a round of
in Chinatown was is the most decorated
film I mean Chinatown is like the
greatest you know Piers Morgan makes a
great point cuz he goes home on you guys
shun all these people but then at the
awards show you get Hollywood man oh man
applause okay and they all stood up and
clapped for the artist that he is now
hold on I get it you're clapping for an
artist I get it but please please
remember what he did Roman Polanski
drugged drugged and [ __ ] raped a 13
year old girl all right that's it that's
not like accusations oh yeah now now
they used the word sodomized I believe
in this context it was oral but I am a
no okay so it was also an SOP when anal
so let's so please hold on Dylan anal so
so if he did well by the way that
doesn't even matter she was 13 and you
were in what your late thirties okay I
yeah and I had this argument with much
people and they were like well you know
time has passed uh and that girl's mom
set her up I go listen mother [ __ ]
you can say that until it's your
daughter you do that to my daughter and
jail is the best thing that's gonna
happen [ __ ] so so and and I
think it brings up a very important
point are their rights and cheers rape
which is [ __ ] serious [ __ ] like that
that is [ __ ] horrify their
ten-year-old right
then there's then there's and then
there's sexual assault which has a very
broad definition I think some of its
battery I don't know that's very
wishy-washy but then there's also
another pronated grip yeah in
appropriate flirting I think I'll order
the appropriate groping like say grab
somebody's
do you think it goes flirting
inappropriate groping sexual assault I
think so
I think that's fair right tell me my
whole life here if your equate irate if
your acquainting rape with with
inappropriate groping I was drunk and
this girl was there and I was attracted
we started making out and I grabbed her
and she's like stop or whatever or
whatever where I made a move on her cuz
I misread a signal now do you think that
my entire livelihood I should never be
able to work again and I should be
excommunicated do you really think
that's what it merits doesn't that take
away from real victims there are real
victims like though that we know Harvey
Weinstein and James Toback we know those
two guys are [ __ ] bad guys I know it
everybody else knows why I wasn't even I
didn't even know I was even in the
circles but I heard about it okay that
doesn't mean that those guys have to
toxify they don't have to make the
entire world for all this other guys
toxic and then create this this sort of
movement where you touched me once and
made me feel uncomfortable so you
assaulted me sexually if you've read
somebody with sexual assault wholly
foster an agent your life is over
supposed entertainment your life is over
good luck selling ticket to me was was
he being flirtatious was he did he did
he kind of like make out with you and
then kind of push the envelope or he's
trying to get in your pants or get like
sexually he's really turned on trying to
figure out where the bail like every guy
yeah where the boundaries are yeah
anybody go no I'm not doing that yeah
maybe he's like oh damn my bat if he
pursues in the other big problem is when
you're in a position of power so you're
somebody's boss and you make an
advancement now the woman is there she
technically if if in any way she feels
pressured she can say you sexually
harassed her and it's a very tough
position because I don't know because
for women it's a very tough place to be
but we have to also make sure we don't
cast women is a hundred percent victims
you got to be responsible for the
position it don't you feel like some of
them I can see when they make these
accusations I look down like oh my god
you're crying out for Fame of course I'm
like you're that legit point and how
ugly are these sexual predators the man
well they are first dogs idiots they
have power and they just look like
[ __ ] troll when you would those
I'm sorry also with Brett Ratner
whoo-hoo I have I know people who know I
don't know him and and Brett Ratner I
have heard is in many ways a very nice
generous guy but I've also heard he's a
you know a lot of this [ __ ] is what he
does and you know whether or not by the
way he's a whether or not he's a
predator or just really aggressive
either way I've been hearing these
stories for as long as they've been in
the business or at least as long as I've
been in the business you hear these
things so that's not a surprise that's
the common thing go like everyone who's
getting busted now like I said it's a
witch-hunt of actual witches no we're
assaulting girls because everyone the
business goes yeah I've been hearing
that for a while everyone yeah all these
guys when I talk to you in there yeah
I've heard that man a bunch of times
yeah and there's more names coming out
next week but here's the other why did
you say something okay let's then let me
tell you why I didn't say something
because it was a rumor and what do you
want to do you want to take to Twitter
and accuse somebody who or whoever I'm
saying I'm saying people people say you
know you knew about it why don't you get
but it's like what do you want me to do
it's a room around Hollywood oh and by
the way excuse me but but go ahead and
and and go ahead and call Harvey
Weinstein at the height of his powers
out for being a sexual predator see what
happens see what happens to your
livelihood see what happens when he has
50 baddest floors anybody he's bad his
lawyers would be on you they would
[ __ ] destroy you yeah they wouldn't
like it you carry for sure yeah so we
have to be you know and Dustin Hoffman
by all accounts a great person and I
guess he told some lewd jokes and made a
girl feel uncomfortable when he was
working on set what are we talking about
here what are we talking about Meryl
Streep recalls Dustin Hoffman grope in
their breasts are in first meeting
that's kind of crazy
what yeah what what's your pinkie you
guys gotta be careful all these guys I'm
not defending anybody but but the thing
is let's be real yeah we don't know them
you don't know how I don't I don't I
don't know no we're fail take away from
let's not take away from that like first
of all who the [ __ ] does that dude who
does that going up to a girl I don't
even know you and I'm gonna grab your
tits right away what what this is insane
this is insane [ __ ] so I don't know I
don't know if this is I don't know you
know again we don't know them I'm not
think about that I'm not talking about
that I'm talking about we need to have a
conversation about degrees we need to
have a conversation about the difference
but I and I get you and I get it in III
actually appreciate that you're a little
bit on the defensive cuz you are but at
the same time there's a real issue I'm
not trying to be a white knight here but
there's a there's an issue for sure yes
and that's why all this has come down I
actually feel ya guys actually like
women act feel that I cold up I can
actually say something I now make a
difference [ __ ] down saying something
everyone goes well if it happened in 88
why are you saying something now well in
88 I couldn't do [ __ ] now social media
and people are bigger influences than
mean our same things so I feel safe
because these guys can't [ __ ] with my
career because they do I'm gonna squeal
like a luck luck luck
Harvey Weinstein James Toback these guys
that are there these guys were [ __ ]
that these guys were taking people's
dignity away from them humiliating them
embarrassing them and maybe even raping
them you know I mean according to that
the allegations against Harvey Weinstein
holy [ __ ]
now that's a bad dude and I don't think
anybody when you have that many women
come forth it's like the Cosby thing I
don't think anybody [ __ ] anybody has
any doubt this guy's a scumbag right but
there B does become this mass hysteria
and it there does he's come on ya know
what but what movie would be like I said
name one guy that they've accused of
we're not like okay like no one's proven
their innocence name one guy well well
in Hollywood that they that someone's
accused Jeremy Piven for example who
flat out denied this and was like I was
never in a in a in a room with you alone
and by the way she two months before
that said that Jared Jared Leto your
boyfriend and yep I know get ready okay
ready to calm down
stay calm stay calm stay calm that's his
[ __ ] him that's his spirit animal she
accused your letter of of on suicide
squad where she was playing some
stripper or something
he she accused him of growling at her
and rubbing his crotch said he was
creepy was a joke erby has a bit of a
history of this used the Joker he's in
character and he puts Moroccan oil in
his hair
yes what do you think I get the egg
white dude I want to get some of that
how about me Morocco
just make my hair look thin I think you
make your hair just fall off you have to
have strong hair from rock and oil it's
Moroccan um yeah I mean I don't know
well I mean pivens defense we know Piven
Piven is a bit of a ladies man ladies
man there's nothing wrong with that at
all he single he does what the hell he
wants my point with her is and if you
look at her social media now you can
tell you can and I wasn't there but I
know Piven pretty damn well you can tell
a person who's actually hurt and isn't
looking for attention and just wants us
to go away and wants to make a change
yep and he can tell from some social
media account who's begging for
attention trying to get famous off the
Jeremy Piven you can tell by someone who
post pictures of their kids on Halloween
and tags drew me Piven saying my
daughters aren't gonna put up with your
[ __ ] either this Halloween or the [ __ ]
sheep ow
you can tell people who are scumbags and
they're taking advantage of this
so-called witch hunt you can really tell
that's that's that's that's the idea
that's what I'm saying that's arms I
don't hang out with women I don't hang
out with womanisers and people are bad
people now I don't really hang out with
Piven but he is a friend yeah and I'm
telling seeing him I've known him in
hairs that's so out of character I can't
even [ __ ] do they also get some the
hottest women in the world and nothing
to get sir but yeah yeah yeah yeah but
you got all my yeah but they you know
this is a conversation that or maybe not
maybe let it all settle and see what
happens
I just worry that you can get a curious
team you can lose everything you
shouldn't be because don't be a scumbag
and shouldn't be worried yeah no don't
be scumbag no no but I'm saying I'm
saying that there are a lot of people
that would you know what are we where we
constitute groping advancement don't
grow [ __ ] don't grope girls and
you'll have a problem [ __ ] don't
croak girls and you don't have a problem
right the people who are worried are the
people who grow girls I I don't know
what true that's it is so it's not true
it's not true that you again miss a lot
I've been following these stories of IVs
and and the problem is in in the
workplace people are losing their jobs
are getting in trouble because for
something that happened 15 years
go and the allegation is you made me
feel uncomfortable
you made an unwanted advance you know
that that's where we're talking about
you groped me and therefore you are
guilty of sexual assault I think we need
to have a conversation about that
because there are a lot of about what
what about what about about like where
you can have one side that just accuses
you publicly on Facebook or whatever it
is and you have no recourse it can wreak
and get there go all your there goes
your job that that's what I that's what
I think is going on in some instances I
think it's I think it's I think that's
the exception you think that's the rule
I hope it's the exception I hope is how
many people have actually lost their job
of women complain that they grow I don't
know I don't know but there are plenty
of people on the verge of it in
Hollywood no not in Hollywood this
didn't start in Hollywood this is Ben's
going on and in a lot of other places I
mean look you know I I don't know Bill
O'Reilly I don't know this was all going
on you know Jamie Horowitz Bill O'Reilly
I don't know these guys I wasn't there
don't know what what happened I'm sure
there was plenty of [ __ ] that went on
they're not probably very good guys I
don't want to defend anybody like that
because I don't know but I'm just saying
that there listen I've had my run-ins
with Jamie Horowitz I know a scumbag
when I see one I'll say that with my
experience oh I think that's yeah I mean
maybe business wisely you don't know
what he's like you know otherwise I
won't defend those guys okay specially
Riley
oh I'm not defending them cuz I don't
know anything about the case I don't
know anything about it
I just know in today's world guilty by
accusation guilty before proven innocent
that's that's what's that's what's going
on with social media
I agree but I also think and I think you
admit this I think there's a real
problem I think there's a real problem
in terms of the fact that there there
are a lot of people who are especially
in my business where if you are a
scumbag with power you can get away with
it not anymore which is a good thing
correct which is a good thing but Sam
Tripoli had a whole thing on it last
night you know Sam tripolis been hanging
out with any problems would take it what
it's worth but he goes all this is is
smoking there's smoke and mirrors so we
become
used to it becomes common for all these
sexual assault cases because it's going
all the way up the chain up to
government oh wow you're so used to
Hollywood and then once we point at the
government and things start to come out
women like well yeah happened here so
we're desensitized to it I said you
might have something there Sam you're a
little crazy a little tinfoil hat yeah
but you might have some but this is the
first time in history that women and men
have worked together so closely used to
be women worked on a farm and Men and
worth of art but for the most part if
you look at actually worked on the phone
well when when traditionally men and
women never work together they never
work together and and in most almost all
cultures they were always separated they
almost voluntarily separated men went
and did this kind of a job women did
this kind of a job even in Scandinavia
it's fascinating the most egalitarian
parts of the country they tried to do
this whole nursing program where they're
like we need to get more men in the
nursing and who's in that evolution be
like yeah I know we keep going back my
god man careful careful about talking
about evolution be careful about talking
about biology because in the the the new
feminist narrative there's no biology
you're not allowed to male and female
gender is a social construct another
should I'm just saying that's the way to
say about that seventeen men and women
you kind of have to work together we've
advanced so much where that narrative
does these are the growing pains right
this is like those oh you're not saying
I'm just I'm just saying it shouldn't be
a growing pain like men women should be
able to work together without the man
constantly trying to grope and flecked
alone well that's the other thing is
like you know I would imagine that if
you make an advance to somebody and they
kind of say like so you and I if I make
an advance to a girl and she's not
interested no prop done stepping off
stepping off right it's when you [ __ ]
uh it's when you make an advance she
says no and you keep doing it and you
keep doing it and pretty soon she's got
to come to work and deal with this
[ __ ] dude who's always doing this how
do you are you supposed to fight back
other than go to human resources I mean
so that's that's that would be sexual
harassment in my opinion you know and I
think that goes on because some dudes
are [ __ ] clueless and dumb
no [ __ ] sir all right uh-huh
no [ __ ] right no but it's we have to
have the conversation we're having it
we're having it and it's important it is
man
all right well that's our time thank you
don't I hope each other don't grow it's
a [ __ ] up word crop' nasty word grope
you do do you think Kevin Spacey could
hold me down know how you jumped on you
to hold him see the fourteen-year-old
got away do you think you'd be able to
no man not unless you really wanted the
ultimate dick died I'd be honest with
you know I might just lay there well can
I be honest well if he puts me in young
man who we're not making fun of a if
they we're not making fun any any
Broadway you don't know yeah yeah
because the comedy show right elicit the
comedy here's a bottle are you I'm just
beginning be honest if you were a little
drunk and cuz you're you like you're a
bit starstruck and if keV like celebrity
dude and if you're a fan of his and if
Kevin well not really right excuse me
it's all right to me hey Manny say what
you will the guy's a [ __ ] great actor
that's like a dick a great actor yeah
yeah he's really do incredible body of
work for sure but ball out the window by
the way he gets on top yeah if he's
gonna put me in house of cards like the
finale
well no I'm saying you're a little drunk
what's in it for me though good night
day what's in it what you're curious I'm
not not with not with him though he's
not attractive again all these guy
gropers are all rightie is Jared Leto
uh-oh he's gonna put me next to a side
squad I don't know bro stop selling your
ass for [ __ ] a part in a movie
well blow that's what's doing wrong
you're drunk you're exciting something
I'd be running and Jared comes in and
goes you know what I just don't care and
you go what well no just dies in your
face let me like speak up my speak up I
mean toss him that script for Suicide
Squad too now I will [ __ ] I'll make
up I'll make a statement right now I'll
make a guarantee of the Jared Leto dives
into your mouth you're gonna let him
kiss you for at least a minute does he
have the gold front sound like Joker I
don't know bro this Brynner
I know his breath is gonna smell perfect
in all Gucci his breath will smell like
possibility and safety you're gonna fall
right into that mouth all right and
you're gonna be like I can't believe I'm
doing this
I'm straight and I'm not telling Brian
or anybody else but dude your years ago
I was leaving a lady's house up in the
hills and I was driving down
I saw jared leto with just this this
chocolate drop dime piece you should
kill she was black you yes sir he's
kissing her goodbye chocolate drop this
little chocolate drop be racist
he was kissed her and goodbye they
probably just got done right music or
something sure and he was in sweats and
I rolled by it like a complete creep
like I just saw the Unabomber no one
knew where he was I mean I just slows
easy unique but he is a unique cat and
by cowboys he's half cat laughter yeah
yeah he makes me look like Adele he's a
dime anyways whoa don't touch me like
that
you by the way grope the [ __ ] out of me
a lot you groped me all you've read my
dick and my rump today everywhere you
taught me that video bail [ __ ] Rock in
here you've put me in
lots of holds against my will this is
true so and that was in the workplace
I'm not famous enough where if you
squeal you know what's gonna keep you
even sprawled on me and really that was
dick first and drove my head with your
dick into the [ __ ] sand and I had a
contusion on my ear I feel like that's
sexual assault on you and I'm just
shooting I was literally just trying to
double like you and you [ __ ] you did
a terribly effective sprawl onto my face
and let me ask you some yeah do you
think like let's say no one's in here
and I decided I'm Kevin Spacey
but I'm six four two and fifty pounds
again now yeah and I wanted to hold you
down and do some [ __ ] to your mouth with
my giant dick yeah could you could you
do anything let's be real though like
dead serious truth is and I've said this
to other guys guys go man kick my ass
and I always said the guys even big guys
ago well you need to understand
something Brendan Schaub could also [ __ ]
you
that's so aggressive be but it's also
true because and that's an important
thing for guys to remember because women
have to walk around like that women have
to walk around like that okay oh yeah
actually put yourself in that position
well now I'm just saying I'm just trying
to be a goof here but I'm saying if no
one good what do you think you just put
me in a [ __ ] move I'd have to wear
you out though like it'd be exhausting
I'd be [ __ ] you're just like I don't
know cuz you're Andy Dufresne that just
fun you got good [ __ ] moves so the
problem is you put me in weird I gotta
get you tired though you can you're good
with the jujitsu so you'd you choke me
unconscious and I'd come to with you
that's a good point it's true how long
would it take you to choke me out be
honest I'm a but look look at my hands
look bro if I was dead so yeah yeah dead
serious but look at her and I was like
super horny you have a look 30 seconds
dirty dirty but look at this how do you
get around that
thirty Seconds thirty attack your imma
break your ankle when he go down to grab
on we'll grab your neck oh that's right
see I'm a [ __ ] giant bendy toy for
you I'm a [ __ ] chew toy for you that
bothers me
you know why then if like Bob Sapp won't
do that to me he could and it's they
look they're levels to this game brother
there's a whole level to this what game
there's a whole packing order and we
know this I that's why I always say
carry a small knife cuz I open you up
zip you unzip you or I just let it be or
I go uh-huh
tell me my hon all right take it you
know what the truth don't go don't make
that weird noise
don't go mmm I don't know there's some
creepy noises I like wait wait do make a
creepy noise watch my you can't do me
just [ __ ] I kind of you know they ask
your name and then you don't make a
noise and you tell me if if it's creepy
or if it's normal okay what's your name
man
Brendon huh I feel like people do that
the borderline right yeah okay now watch
this
what's this how much you weigh 250
pounds super creepy huh
what Kevin Spacey all right wait hold on
ready what's your nationality
Native American
that's strange Super Stretch oh you make
one no let's make a quest no I'm all
pale I wouldn't feel attractive no hey
would you do for Halloween I haven't
seen you since Halloween I had to say
yesterday off my son was dressed like a
ghost and he had this you said sheets
and eyes cut out old school
it sucked and he goes who made it it was
actually bought cos had electronic eyes
that he had to carry a box it kept
falling out him and it sucked and we
were tucking his pants I guess keeps
falling and he just finally [ __ ] took
it off why not just take a roll facing
my eyes out now you took another threw
it on the ground he goes this is stupid
he just walked around in a black shirt
and black be careful cuz the ghost if
you do do the pillowcase can look like
KKK
well yeah when I was little my dad I
can't go out don't ya know pillowcases
stick up and cut the eyes out you'll be
careful oh yeah let's get my let's not
do I look like a racist yeah I couldn't
figure out why my dad's like well you
look like KKK I'm like right which will
restore to the side so just we're
[ __ ] aware yeah he's a ghost ghost
well I don't know he's a little racist
that's [ __ ] up
little white supremist oh the little
whites brim did you see that [ __ ]
hilarious Instagram video of the guy
pull this up on oh my god Jim Breen he's
okay he's just giving out let me let me
find it he's just giving out random [ __ ]
on Halloween to kids I was laughing so
[ __ ] hard time out on the big brown
breakdown hell it sucks and give out
like fruit or pennies or change yeah
some guy tagged me goes look at this son
of a [ __ ]
he was giving out ready for this be
chocolate-covered onions the guy goes
this guy goes this kid post goes what
kind of sicko gives out a
chocolate-covered there's a big fat
onion that's so funny to me that's so
[ __ ] funny oh my god
which one's this no I'm pulling it up
right now he's it weird that I got
nervous that he brought them I thought
he was bringing up pictures on my phone
I was like wait let me check hold like
that teacher did yeah oh my god
I'm a dick yeah right there the
Halloween Sun yeah watch this and then
instead of candy brand yeah there you go
you're the guy who's giving out truck
covered onions what kind of sicko
is the kid bites you yeah I went to
Montana street cuz all the stores oh
yeah they just give up all the stores
shut down but then all the owners just
give out candy all the kids yeah it was
packed great costumes but some dude was
in a legit like Disneyland Mickey Mouse
costume like they're all kids me and
they see Mickey they [ __ ] freak out
so he's covered in kids and he's going
alright art cuz he has his kidneys going
alright alright I gotta get gone I'm
like bro you came as Mickey Mouse
you dumbass okay so you don't know no
you look like you are a paid employee of
like Tom Cruise at the mall you're gonna
get mom dude he was going all right
we're trying a woman oh no no cuz tigers
loves make it like you chillin you're
hang on why I'm gonna pull you man are
you chilling I was like I lift up tiger
I'm like look high-five him the guy's
like he's doing this like you chill for
a while - there's a line
like what the [ __ ] do you think was
gonna happen and where do you get that
out that's amazing talking he must maybe
work there stole it the straight up
Mickey Mouse from disallow kids [ __ ]
everywhere just god no wrong [ __ ]
costumes legit Mickey Mouse yeah he was
so frustrated you tell his kid was like
god damn it man cuz I couldn't go
anywhere
my wife worried like she was dressed
like a llama I gotta be honest Allah was
adorable
a llama [ __ ] yes she have a little tail
she had curly little head little hoodie
and curly curly little thing oh you'd
look like a llama like the up off of
Emperor's New Groove it was just like a
pink but furry suit like as IP a pink
jumpsuit and she's a pig no cuz she was
a pillow she had curly hair she had a
little tail little llama tail a little
nose on the top it was so cute I was
like you [ __ ] cute she had parades I
was like furry actually I was I he
[ __ ] you forgive a man I know you
listen show you that's llamas are pink
no super confusing club no you're a
unicorn you don't know she was a pink la
musica you me I was dressed I got she
bought she put me I got a red outfit on
it had horns but they were kind of like
bull horns you're a death-row I don't
know it was shitty little cow horns with
a shitty tail and a little soft nose so
it was a hood with a soft nose on the
[ __ ] end it sucked it was an tiny
[ __ ] wings the hold of shitty wig you
could never flies just go over there
yeah she was a pink llama yeah Dora you
were a shitty Satan I was a red I was
already how I was a Red Cow than your
son yeah kind of a white supremecy n--
yeah that kept falling and what was your
daughter well alright so I'm glad you
asked now do the counts do howling the
worst in America the worst you can
imagine would you saw into it she's
awesome but I I don't do anything of
course cuz mmm bad dad but I yeah I saw
there I am with my my it's a you
understand what I'm saying right it's
like a it's got booties and you get into
it it's jumpsuit it's zip so who does me
good trip soon then I got my hood I put
it over right so I got 20 whole dozen
pictures anyway I don't know I got it I
threw it away in the middle it got too
hot my daughter
was dressed as a an archer sort of she
had an archery outfit on sort of like
she was dressed like a forest Archer and
a little shitty bow like Robin yeah and
I said you're a Huntress and she goes no
I'm not
I go okay she goes I shoot a bow and
arrow and that was her custom so it was
yeah it bit of a closer feels a little
bit that's what Halloween is yeah
Halloween is so fun I watch the kids
they get so accept through Montana
Street was a blast
a black cute I take my son on this one
he's super scared of spiders right now
cuz they're spiders that movie trolls
so whatever spiders always freak out but
there's this spider that's on this stop
sign by where I live the [ __ ] web is
huge man and there's this fat spider
from prehistoric days on real one I call
him Jack the spider we just walked him
every morning and the spiders out and
right when we're walking up every more
we were doing this for six weeks we
always check this buy up some black guy
you know cuz I live by the stairs yeah
some black guy him his friend right
forget he's like oh [ __ ] man like the
spider his friends goes oh no that's a
garden spider I was like god dammit man
I'm afraid of spiders
god damnit I'm not afraid I was I was in
my bushes in in back in the day I was
living on sunset off of sunset I was in
the bushes we had this IV and I was and
I was trying to get this ball for my dog
and I'm in the bushes and I and I'm
standing there in the in the mirror and
my girl screams and this giant spider
had been on my back and it crawled and
dude if you ever want to see me turn
into a coward that'll do it I went like
you you can't get it all fastness you
can't get it off your body it was it was
such an ass - don't do it to me using
any other do snakes not wasp - oh my god
bees not really [ __ ] centipedes wanna
buy centipede centipede a bite the lip
well we had Cody Cody what's his name on
I not seen it he said he said centipedes
are terrible but I know if you live in
[ __ ] Bermuda this [ __ ] no there's
not those giant bite England I think
there might be asked him about it really
asked them really yeah they're not here
if you like go [ __ ]
Marsden can you look up also winter lat
peas may be the last person you've met
that got bit by those giant centipede
it's true the small ones is whatever you
don't really want like growth there's
these giant dinosaur centipede yeah
you're right well he's doing um he's
still getting swollen many types of
California Santa beats Oh tiger
centipede Oh fifteen inches dude that's
the gnarly one right oh yeah let's see
their fangs often with a venomous bite
that can be very painful
that means honey we flex with the house
impede that you know what you do with
those click so the tiger centipede
reaches 15 centimeters I don't know what
that means can exhibit a number of
colors a lot of 15 inches aggressive oh
not aggressive
have you ever seen what those in your
house no never the paint bite can be
very painful House centipede ranges
through California very common all right
here's my big deal it's fine dude yeah
soil say you mean in California is
swishing damage I worry more about black
widows everywhere yeah black widows they
hurt kill yeah no not grown men but kids
kidnap just hurt you like a [ __ ]
can allergic so we'll just died from a
bite from a rattlesnake in Denver no a
runner
really yeah yeah I guess his heart was
pumping so fast that the poison probably
pumped it into his heart
nope no he was a ultramarathon runner
rogen had the lady who won on and he got
bit and then he was going in and out of
it I I forget what I was and then they
flew him but yeah he died from it I
imagine your body so no he had to note
new you know it is like the usual n't
killed grown man he had allergic
reaction to some yeah Ralph snake would
[ __ ] suck no that hurts
well cuz also gnarly snakes it can also
dead in your leg so you can lose the use
of your leg you know dogs have that yeah
there you go Denver Post Wow
been killed by rattlesnake Ironman
athlete they all that's in there and
she's Asian use asian asian alright hike
in Jefferson County trail
let's see even training oh yes by
polar disorder yeah keep going keep
going
I was funny with gin oh we had bipolar
just like it matters I keep going I'm
just saying that's not the reason he
died yeah keep going
but it's just a big story oh yeah I mean
guy got bit by a rattlesnake running
that's a bummer man
see there's a shooting in dimmer Walmart
well Thornton
that's like outside that's not taking
the Denver what happened to they know
the guy's dead though
the shooter I think did he die I said
they took him into custody I heard he
died I don't know
only shot I don't say only but wasn't it
just - I felt businesses and it run-ins
with the police arrested yeah I don't
think there are a lot of people in
Denver apparently out there who have
guns right they carry guns yeah I mean
everywhere yeah well that's what we
worry about terrorists can I just stop
for a second we worry about terrorists
like Islamic terrorists white dudes
white disgruntled dudes in their 30s 40s
and 50s
and now 60s those might be the ones that
we might want to quarantine that's
general I'm just saying I'm just saying
I just get a kick out of how we worry
about Islamic terrorists but there are a
lot of well I mean New York is LA
mctarry just killed nine people yes and
this guy killed two people and the guy
through the [ __ ] don't Thomas and
Patek well I mean the vacation [ __ ] him
yeah yeah
the the the guy who killed the people in
New York and they've seen more of it and
but they're gonna start putting up
around I don't know how you doing in New
York but they we have it here in LA in
Santa Monica especially third Street
they have those big cement like barriers
so cars can't get there Venice has it
now too right guy drove down Venice and
killed that married couple you know like
maybe two three years ago went on the
boardwalk ran over oh that just made so
now there's this huge barricades of the
Farscape I'm sorry unless you're cop so
in New York that's what happened so
there you're gonna see it all over they
said they're gonna start putting money
well Jimmy Burke I talked
and Jimmy Burke my boy from New York who
takes that route every single day that
exact route and he's on his bike and his
bike every day he's on his bike that
that route because he has a client down
there and he plays tennis down there
every day yeah he was so bunched up he's
like I wanted to do something they were
there they heard the sirens and
everything they were he was down there
yeah truck can do a lot of damage that
guy they I mean they got the he didn't
kill himself the Yellin alive right
which is usually odd you can get more
info on the track where where you know
they said he got his information off
Isis online and like them telling him
exactly what to do it's crazy man yeah
so three dead Walmart and he was just a
dude who just sick of life failed
businesses went and shot him yep hey I
wonder if they're gonna be fine annoyed
Robert Sapolsky who did Rogen's podcast
like he was talking about he said what
do you think we're gonna as we study
brain science what do you think we're
gonna find out later on and he said I
think what you're gonna find is that
when we learn more about the brain and
you hear about people like these
shooters or people who do things we're
gonna go oh my god God he was sick what
a shame and we're all gonna be and
they're gonna be able to point to
something in his brain that happened
where he basically went crazy like a lot
of cases but like with this guy who
failed businesses runs you know I'm
saying like bunch of failed businesses
just like [ __ ] this man so so so these
events right that's awesome
yes but so this shows so the idea would
be that it'd be like were his business
of failure was he a failure because
there was something wrong with his brain
so they had this you ever hear that
state that um statistic where they say
if you're married men who are married or
people who are married tend to be
happier
well that's true based on all the
metrics available when they do all these
social scientists do these studies like
married people study have you however
the other thing maybe also is that happy
people also tend to get married more
than depressed people so what comes
first you know the chicken or the egg
and there's a lot of cases like that
where somebody who's married also tends
to be more attractive to other people
I'm sorry somebody's happiest person
right so you know sometimes you know
there may have been a problem already
with
sky you know I don't know it's gonna be
interesting as we learn more as a single
then say I'm sure look at that haircut
man you look way older than 47 she's
like Brendan's dude hey don't say that
oh you called man up pretty good look at
his hair it's it's shaved on the sides
and that's a terrible pink collar and
sweater I don't dress like that
is he my age 47 he's younger looks older
way older
all right good he's having the exact
same haircut it's whatever no we don't
take that back please
five facts you didn't know about him so
do we call him a white extremist no just
a crazy [ __ ] what wouldn't it's white
people it's it's you yeah yeah right
mental disorder right when they're why
it's a mental disorder when it's what
he's Muslim what he's round it's a
terrorist yeah yeah [ __ ] Jane right
that's actually yeah that's true but
then again that [ __ ] guy who had
pledged allegiance to Isis and who the
guy in the truck they found oh yeah he's
they found a note I'd be a terrorist I
found a note you know I see trumps
trying to give give him the death
penalty again he might be crazy too I
mean again let's rock yeah but let's
don't get all info out of them that we
can and then kill him I agree with
trembling let's kill him what do you do
you put in prison yeah that's a whole
nother conversation no I'm for the death
penalty a lot of cases I really am yeah
I mean in other words like okay so you
kill kids are you're crazy I don't
really care I mean I don't want you
around the whole thing it stops like
kids though like you kill this and
people in New York another path the ISIS
tastes they have that a lot of states
you know still the death penalty exists
for that reason so I for not kind of
[ __ ] I don't know if that's the best way
to run society it's always been
controversial right the idea is does the
death penalty deter criminal behavior
that was always the argument right so if
it does so so if people know that they
might die if they commit this crime
they're likely not to do
if that knowledge feels so crazy it's
almost an out form right yeah especially
the way we kill them right but that's
kind of peaceful in it yes but I think
it's also it relates to premeditated
murder so premeditated murder is
different so when you land it yeah
typically they die logic goes well we're
gonna plant killing this guy if we get
caught I don't just go to jail forever
I die yeah that can that can have I
don't know if there's any real science
to prove its a deterrent but you know
there is some evidence that could be a
deterrent it would be for me but you're
the same person the people that
criminals and stuff like that you know
they don't that but they also do it
because they don't think they're gonna
get caught yeah well I was gonna do
another the assumption there I would
imagine it creates more tension and you
might think twice before you do it it
might save some ladders old criminals
really don't think like that yeah they
probably do I mean if you know you're
gonna die versus go to jail versus maybe
you can beat it in court there's all
kinds of things I don't know I mean I've
when I plan murders I do it in states
where I know I'm gonna dance or spell
yeah yeah yeah Dexter style that's right
that was weird how you just burst your
lips and pushed you let your mouth down
you guys didn't see that because well
they'll see it on there no because you
were hiding behind the mic you think oh
yeah I take those things into
consideration hey can we just talk a
little bit about I'm sorry to make this
jump but with the card of the year I
know your hog I mean good thing you
brought that up the card of the year
I've gotta get you're taking a number
I'm gonna you know give me your tickers
I don't what you copy no much we bring
up the whole you mean you have to see it
well I'm I can rip through them because
the beasts car of the year yeah well so
we got we got let's go you want to go
big to a tall big I can't wait so
there's GSP there's Michael Bisping we
don't start the train that be well let's
start with the hiring event otherwise
virus on this why would I listen to any
of it alright although under cards are
good too
OS peevish Corey Anderson is a fun one
Mickey gall you know he's on the come
Oh who's Mickey boy I don't know Randy
brown sorry
that's usually how it goes from Mickey
go unless he's fightin CM Punk do you
know much about Randy brown he was on
that Dana White lookin for a fight he
was on looking for a fight with Dean
right that's how you got a shot at this
I like what they're doing Mickey guy
he's only four no like this guy's 92 so
his more experience but for Mickey gall
the kid has talent charisma he's beating
some big names as far as big names that
people recognize not the toughest guys
but there's no reason to throw him to
the [ __ ] wall they're bringing him up
which is smart which is usually you
don't really get that yeah this is good
yeah yeah I mean it kicks off with
Johnny Hendrix verse the dimepiece basta
watching me eraser um
and Johnny Johnny Hendrix looking
thicker than a [ __ ] enchilada he's
looking at Becky looks like a breed I
like it I said she was strong it looks
like a thick yeah gordito I've heard I
get gordita Chris I have seen him on in
the off season at a distance but he
definitely gets much bigger I've heard
as big as 220 pounds Italia sure he said
that's okay now he's fighting in 85 here
right yep and he still misses weight and
but he did change camps and he says he
didn't go undefeated who is he who is he
he's with Jackson's down which I call
that's like going to Florida for a
retirement home
Jackson's camp is like Kevin's waiting
room is that right well no they have
world-class fighters but you see a lot
of guys then to their career make the
move to Jack okay it's like the last
hoorah right like I said it's like
moving down good memory you don't know I
just say it's too late it's just - it's
over it gets game it's I love Johnny I
do man he's one of my favorite people in
the world but like you think you think
you're putting money on Paul oh yes the
only reason why Johnny's on the card is
cuz they're hoping the old fans who are
tuned in to George st. Pierre going oh
[ __ ] I know Johnny because that was
George's last fight yeah that's why
George that's why Johnny's on the card
otherwise he would never be on there so
they're hoping though those old George
st. Pierre fans recognize Johnny Hendrix
all right
I'll go with Costa um he got wonderboy
of smalls mazepa Dolph oh and I don't
know if two-nicorn eventually mouths
word on Bisbing getting into it it's on
the current thing yes I'm I didn't see
that
whooo hate each other because I'm coming
Maz Vidal is a beast
if Maz here's my here's my take on it
obviously if Maz Badal stands a little
too far it's gonna get eaten up with
those legs but if Maz banal can stand at
a boxer's this little boy is not a leg
kicker no and so if if Maz brawl can
crowd Wonder Boy and they start
exchanging I got Mazda honest as great
as one of way is one of was a killer but
Maz banal is [ __ ] game he's got such
good hands I don't know I think I think
I think way if it comes down to boxing I
think Mazda at all if you can keep that
distance so how do you got for god sakes
don't keep safe comes down a box and it
comes because it's gonna come down to
mixed martial arts I got Wonder Boy yeah
wonder what I do hope that yep I think
what Maz ball is a beast but I at the
end of the day I got I got Wonder Boy I
got Mazda thought decision
I got moms with all decision really
because I think he's more dynamic I
think I just think it's Maz but all's
time he's a big [ __ ] one seven-year
he's in his prime he does everything
really really well we're one of boiling
does one thing great
I just think Maz Walken can figure that
code out really hmm Wow he's been do it
too long I think it's mods wells time so
you think it was ball wins and get some
eggs you think he crowds him you think
he stays he doesn't he does whatever he
doesn't have to crowd him he's a good
enough dynamic striker he doesn't need
to crowd him he can he can stay on the
outside and not get knocked out ain't
get on the inside he's better grappler
he's a better boxer I just think he's
more game I think for wonder boy don't
you know his first fight with Tyrone was
was a amazing fight which on the big
round baked I said was boring I'm
correct to myself that first one was
amazing second one was awful and I think
there's a bitter taste in everyone's
mouth for wonder boy so I think there's
a lot more pressure on Wonder Boy the
loser of this fight goes to the back to
the queue at 170 it's not a fun
I think Maz Woodall wins and gets a you
know he has a good claim for a title
shot definitely over Kobe Covington then
you got you on averse Rose hmm Rose
looking like 11 from stranger things
there yes yes correct
Rose looks like a yes kind of a asian
ish 11 you always talked about how
insanely athletic Rose is which which I
take to believe if she's in a good camp
she just continues to improve and
improve and improve so you know the
underdog there's Rose for sure I was the
biggest underdog on the code yeah we got
B III always have to go with you on that
just in terms of what I just don't see
anyone beat you on affair very very
times she's so much leaps and bounds
better than every girl in that division
she's gonna become like a Mighty Mouse
typisch where she just gonna murk people
[ __ ] incredible
the UFC should get behind her little
more it's tough what you know with
English but yeah yeah but Rose is so
sneaky with her jiu-jitsu if you're--if
knows can get to the you know bring it
she has the he'll marry ya opportunity
here was machine where Johanna can train
with whoever she wants I've seen Rose do
certain things where you can't really
train for it she can pull one of those
out it could be a huge upset yeah but
yeah if if Rose wins
I believe Rose wins on the ground with a
submission well if there's a see I don't
think it's on the ground I think she
would jump to it from an underhook or
standing that's where she's gonna get it
but denied you just do something you're
gonna try if there's a finish it's from
Rose yeah you know by submission I say
they got Cody gar Brett TJ Dillashaw I
do the greatest fight up and away to
vault though yeah that's gonna be
ridiculous when TJ did our show I asked
him about that and he was a dim as a
while ago yep and he basically said that
Cody comes straight forward doesn't
fight with angles and I was like oh I
can't wait to see this fight I'm gonna
go with that TJ Dillashaw
I think TJ's so phenomenal obviously so
is Cody
Cody's got I guess more power in his
hands
[Music]
yeah but I'm just gonna go TJ I think
TJ's ultimately more creative as a
fighter I think he's just he just steps
it up and does crazy [ __ ]
I'll have TJ for other reasons I also
think it's really hard to train for TJ
cosy PJ training together you know that
right for years I did not know that yeah
I did not know that so they know a lot
of math what do you think you have you
have TJ I've TJ for other reasons I
don't want to get into but I think TJ
wins by decision and then they do a
rematch I think Cody wins you're gonna
see a trilogy of this fight cuz it's
gonna be a barn burner it's best item
bantamweight history Bisbing GSP main
event
so you've trained with both these guys
for years yep um I don't know III die
die I mean this is he's four years he's
been off for years now you throw him in
the huge arena with Michael Bisping only
get state's rate big enough for GSP I'm
not worried about him not performing
yeah otherwise a great champion I don't
know you got a pick so so G ESPYs let me
stop you though you're wearing those
business sucks again I know the richer
poor guys reached out to me I get I'm
sending you thought really yeah thank
you guys I need him and I will wear them
uh here's here's here's what I'm gonna
say don't don't look at that look up at
my face massage um GSP has that diving
double and single and he puts you on
your back Michael Bisping has amazing
takedown defense okay I think those two
things might neutralize themselves let's
just say now they're left on their feet
Michael Bisping has problems with that I
I I think the root thing that just be so
good at is finding your one weakness
your one blind block level unintended
and I wouldn't be surprised if yeah if
he
play devil's advocate freebie what what
about George fighting at 85 for the
first time having to go five rounds what
happened
what about that heavy extra weight that
he's never fought at going to the fourth
and fifth round where Michael Bisping
literally has the best cardio at 85 I
would answer this of all time yeah he's
gone five rounds many times yes by 70
yes before you saw to kick them yes
carry on
so at 70 I feel like 85 when you're not
sucking that much weight actually might
help you cuz you're more hydrated you're
bigger bigger but more hydrated and
let's face it GSP when he was on an
offseason at least according to Nate
Marquardt was walking at 190 sometimes
195 that kid so he's thicker now though
he's thicker now he's definitely thicker
older but I think you know IV 85 ZZ ER
for him then then is 70 and I don't know
the sucking down 270 at his size after
four years would have helped this car do
I feel like this helps this car do so
I'm not so worried about his cardio yeah
but it's a different body I don't know
you know you brought up USANA it's a
different game now you have to take that
into account Bisbing spot eight times
since George Reed last but that's and
he's fought the best of the best yeah
and beat him yeah yeah like Anderson
Silva like Luke Rockhold you know Dan
Henderson Dan Henderson so and is
Michael a little bigger a little
Michael's for sure bigger it's for sure
bigger hun percent bigger man yeah 100%
yeah biz means not a small dude nothing
is that big dude arms are huge let's
know I'm sorry it's been but well did
they're pretty thick I've spend enough
time with them where I'm like Jesus
that's a thick [ __ ] guy he's thick so
you know what oh you're such a [ __ ]
GSP oh I just play devil's out with an
old jellyfish jellyfish oh my dears here
SP we're gonna get all right well let me
play those em for GSB all right all
right it's probably the best champion
the UFC has ever had all about that
okay tell me nothing I don't know and he
also has the best job of all time which
is his left is what I call an educator
jab from the
boxing circles but if he wanted to I
don't know if he wants to if he wanted
to do you think George could get in a
crouched stance and stick behind his jab
for five boring rounds and win every
round by using just a jab because his
bidding taking him down
nope Michael's not taking him down
there's no God no I think doesn't take
people down does does Michael figure out
that jab after two three rounds Michael
such an experienced striker no one's
ever figured it out so does Bisbing do
it for the first time ever Saturday
night no yeah ever yeah he'd ever he
does yeah he does he has the best to me
the best trained coach of all time and
that's really because he's getting him
ready for the jab [ __ ] yeah that no one
else can figure out damn right no lumps
if he starts figuring out and by
figuring out do you mean starts counter
it with the right hand that's what I
think so then does it leave them open
for a double leg in George st. Pierre
some would argue is the best double leg
of all time having double don't say
diving I like diving because he drives
his I mean we call that a diving double
Ron in my school um man so are you
saying maybe there's Jab Jab Jab Jab Jab
Jab kind of right dull a now you're on
the ground yep now Michael's trying to
stand back up
George's wrestling to keep you back down
now it's a ground-and-pound Bisbing
getting grounded pounded well here's the
thing yeah now Michael Bisping is also
the best that cage Kron standing at
right you take him down sure it's Rashad
Evans Tim Kennedy Valley's Chael Sonnen
yeah so there you go all bigger men all
bigger men that he climbed the cage on
so and it's five rounds and it's five
[ __ ] around no one has better cardio
than Bisby Oh any other
chip-on-the-shoulder
cuz again he's the underdog and if he
does beat him there's argument for job
Michael bismi be the best middleweight
of all time if you look at his resume
there's a legit argument and say well
everyone's faster primarily five is he
the second most winning fighter in UFC
he's the winningest fighter he's the
winning is pretty sure he's the
winningest fighter talking about an
accomplishment oh it took him 10 years
to get it up it took him 10 years again
and he probably was yeah yeah
um Frank Mir mmm that's from number of
fights go back this would go back go to
go to the the best records in UFC
history so at middleweight he's the most
successful of all time
yes PS so brilliant he's so brilliant
he's his fight IQ so high it's so high
Michael Bisping Sparky's pretty high
yeah yeah I'll say this these these are
my other caveats before you give your
official pick and when you're riding
down in your official pick my fan base
is waiting on it yeah the thing that
bothers me about this is again why is
GSP coming back for what motives did he
have to come back is because the paydays
and the the stardom that UFC fighters
have these days she's not really
strapped you know I'm saying I can I
tell you what I hold on to it or you
know it in he also admit again an
interview how he's terrified to fight he
doesn't enjoy fighting which is strange
to me but he says he misses the
limelight Michael Bisping is a straight
up fighter through and through winning
his fighter in UFC history it's all
awesome all Mike all Michael so when the
going gets tough loves it you're gonna
have to kill Michael Bisping loves it
that's what he does
and Bisbing realized what's at stake
here he's gonna be the the most
successful middleweight of all time he
already is I don't think anything you
said about Mike GSP wasn't true when he
was a champion I think he didn't like
fighting as much he was game has changed
the rack the game has changed yeah and
you've taken four years off so there's
just there's all these sort of X factors
he's um having said all that he also
loses who does Michael Bisping not too
many people know too who know the croc
all this away I don't know plenty of
people you knocked Luke Robinson
yes he did no I'm saying I'm saying the
only person that just he's ever lost to
well to people Matt Hughes and and Matt
Serra
he finds a way to win he finds a [ __ ]
way to win it four years ago four years
ago and why did you stop you know he's
always made to be curious because real
fighters don't take that much time off
so so that the the reason the feeling I
get is that why would he come back one
is he bored with his life is is his life
is does he miss the excitement too or
does he miss purpose-to if you're coming
back for the limelight or the money or
whatever you miss look at the dick on
him in that picture by the way it's
going up how did you not notice that
well it look more like it was pointing
so I didn't want to bring it up all the
way up but I guess is it coming no it
looks like a [ __ ] submarine telescope
yeah
trick photography no it looks like it's
pointing straight out but I guess it's
coming no it's got the cup though no
it's bent up it might be the coupler has
a cup like that what cup is diagonal
like a clock well if you worried dick
straight up yeah yeah uh body his body
looks different he's older bro face
looks different he's at 85
he's not gonna be a shredded are you
sure goddamn pic Bryan Callen I'm just
giving you all the facts here cuz I'm
gonna go Michael Bisping I think it's
are you gonna switch yeah I think it's
such a mountain for Georges st. Pierre
to climb I have to go with Michael
Bisping that's a big man George st.
Pierre the best as he is the best of all
we're on four year layoff is Mary who
can sit behind a jab and I'll jab anyone
double like anyone in the world yeah has
taken down guys who were better at
wrestling
yeah the Bisbee and I would say to you
that yeah my hope has been figured
[ __ ] Anderson Silva out and did he cuz
I ever Civil knocked them out yeah and
then he came back and beat him and
someone knocked him out yeah came back
and beat him I don't know you'd say
figured him out he won the fight it was
a hell of a fight fight of the year
yeah there's no figuring out they both
got [ __ ] up yeah there's no figuring
out it wasn't like oh he shut him down
figuring out shutting him the hole and
just be figured I'll hold Michael
bisby's game is only his eye and that's
a big thing but he's been winning with
no the hole in Michael Bisbing his game
it could be to his eye but he does get
hit but
speeds not a knockout artist yeah he's
not GSP is a very cautious fighter in
fact I'll jab your eye up jab your eye
good jab your eye up higher good jab
your eye out and off with jab and I ask
Koscheck I've been winning as well
you do yes yeah I also think this card
and people like you such a hater on the
skirt no I'm not a hater I can't wait
for this goddamn card
I just think looking at the matchups in
them on the main card you're gonna get a
lot of decisions I think one two three
four I think you get four decisions out
of five on the main card there's nothing
wrong with that
I think they're still exciting fights I
just think for the casual family might
god damn it for me I like when it goes
all the rounds cuz you see guys camps
you see their actual game plan the
techniques what's a quick finish
it's whatever people get happy because
they want blood because we're in
gladiator days but I like she like when
goes decision I just think I still think
you're good fights and exciting fights I
just think you're getting four out of
five decisions on my own card if GSP
pulls it off that's that'll be just
[ __ ] unbelievable I mean it's it for
years yeah I think the other reason just
became came back is especially at 85 is
he thinks he sees a [ __ ] in biz beings
game because I will tell you this right
now if you're Romero Luke Rockhold and
Whitaker we're the champs he would not
be fine 285 just too big for him no he
wouldn't do it yeah Whitakers smaller
than Bisbee but he wouldn't do it when
those guys would knock him out no
there's a reason why it's a perfect
storm for him to fight at 85 and get the
belt and he's not gonna defend it he's
gonna vacate the belt and go 270 okay
you won't see him ever fight 85 again I
promise you that yeah he doesn't mind
part of those guys know what doesn't
make sense yeah he's not a natural 85
it's what those guys are too big too
fast too strong you see Conor McGregor
mmm sure Conor McGregor did he had his
premiere for his movie uh yeah and they
asked him out him fighting Tony first
and this stuff now is it current events
can just rip off on it go for it huh so
they asked him out like what's next and
all the stuff and he goes listen for me
to fight I'm a different level now he is
I'm gonna do need to be a co promoter
alright you're not seeing him fight for
a while
when I saw that I went eh I always say
no you're worth good for you I love that
cuz he's the only guy history who's ever
been a bigger baby I said you ain't seen
him fight for a long time okay Morgan
say I was gonna say did you think that's
because that's a convenient way of
ducking no afraid of minute oh god how
do we cry yeah no God no God no no he he
knows Toni Ferguson's the fight it's
actually a good fight for him it's a
good fight for Toni it's good fight for
Conor
no one's ducking anyone at that careful
uh it's none of that it's just he's
going you want me to fight I'm gonna
differently doesn't he worried that that
not fighting can have an effect on his
ability to win like just ring rust and
all that don't those guys worry about
that I'm sure a little bit but when you
have a hundred million in a bank and
they're like eh we need to fight at
t-mobile Arena we're gonna pay you know
four million ten million goes well we'll
have 100 million oh yeah and I'm bigger
than anyone I'm bigger than all you guys
sent in this table including you Dana
yeah what do you want to do yeah like
I'm a different level mate same thing
with Anthony Joshua like I had this talk
with my boy Brian from Showtime
yesterday so Anthony Joshua has one
fight left on his Showtime contract his
promoter Hearns this is fastening like
the game is fascinating to me so Anthony
and Joshua come so big HIDA and this is
this relates to what Connors doing in
certain boxers the Floyd Mayweather it's
very rare but anthe Joshua's become so
big in such a powerhouse and he doesn't
need the promoter Hearns anymore you
don't need him so once this contracts up
you Justin go now I'm just gonna do anti
Joshua promotions yeah I get the gate I
get this I'm the name so Conor McGregor
for the first time ever in mixed martial
arts history goes man I'm a Beloit made
whether it makes martial arts you're not
gonna pay me these Pete and when I say
peanuts he's still the high Spade
comparative weight compared Lee he's
going no man I'm the LeBron James of
mixed martial arts now we're not doing
his right you're not my boss anymore
what we are is if anything we're part
you know the Mart always says I'm worth
this yes and you need me so now it's
gonna be a Conor McGregor promotion with
the UFC it's right I'm gonna go to
Dublin I need part of the gain of that
75,000
because that's why I'm making my mom
called business and merge Reebok we're
not doing this $200,000 license deal
anymore I can sell my own shirts online
to make way more than yeah so what do
you guys want to do you're living the
golden age
what's up it's great I think it's great
I do too I like you but the only issue
is if you're Connor Finn you don't seem
fight for a while because you've seized
they've not have to deal with this so
like what the [ __ ] do we do cuz if you
set this president then well my guys
down the road are gonna start to figure
my guess is Dan is only one voice in the
room and whether or not and he's got to
deal with a board well we shot our you
manual right yeah so you have already a
man who's probably they'll play ball
they're used to this they have no
problem playing ball with a belt they've
dealt with bigger diva than culture or
they just are Emmanuel they're also dumb
add some the biggest names in the world
here it's also a group of people in a
room who all have a stake in this and
Dana it has a lot of expertise but he's
only one voice at the end of the day if
everybody else is into it he's got a
he's got to go along well here's the
other thing be you if you're the UFC if
you're Dana White if you're WME IMG you
ready you have to play Connors game yeah
you have no other option correct fine go
do your own thing man correct we don't
need you you don't just the lowest year
of all time without me fighting is it is
it by the way yes yeah last time to pay
Brees back to back where this low was
UFC 47 oh wow it's just again it's it's
the flow of sports it goes up and down
and ratings and there's all this stuff
but it's just you know when you
superstars not fighting you have the
biggest superstar of all time going nah
man a lot of that might be mismanagement
to make superstars figure out a way to
make them you know bring them up slowly
or whatever so here we go they've got to
enticed me now because I came from a
billion dollar fight which is the in
people you always exactly know what
actually was a billion dollar fight
billion dollar fight so they've got to
entice me with something I want equity I
want ownership I want to be true
partners in this similar the way I was
in the Floyd fight I was a promoter I
was a fighter that must continue for me
to continue otherwise I've got many
entities and many other interests that
can carry on
I'm also already set financier but we're
in negotiations it's true amazing
amazing my thick-ass able to do great
though yeah and don't get wrong I know
people like oh come on man get back in
there I get all that but from a business
side it's so cool yeah do you think he's
gonna change the game for the everyone
else do you think it'd be all right cuz
he's been fighting for so long you think
it'd be all right walking away from
fighting at the end hundred percent you
do right yeah I mean it why wouldn't you
be right well he's up because he's a
fighter and it's what he loves to do
however he's also also done it for so
long he was almost gonna retire before
all this [ __ ] he was gonna retire but he
also tweeted out a while ago getting get
paid get out yeah like that those are
his word yeah this game you know and
listen Hollywood is calling for this guy
my Game of Thrones predator I mean the
biggest rush can imagine he doesn't want
to do it because wanna focus on fighting
yeah
only have $100,000,000 you know it's
kind of you're just like no I'm not
gonna do that right you let me fight who
for how much that's crazy right it's
just a different Lane but and you can be
upset and frustrated Conor McGregor but
yeah I look at a different angle where I
go man he's he's opening the door for
fighters down the road to now you know
if he gets equity he has some share and
he has some say in the way they treat
fighters and he's a fighter and he has
his own promotion he can start maybe
start getting it towards our way a
little bit it's all good man yep I think
it's fantastic
why don't you jump some current events
cool you guys are always real quick sure
sure you got a piss gen yep you're
taking [ __ ] [ __ ] at this oh wow
alright we're back here we're back here
current events current events
stop running your fingers to your
silkiest [ __ ] hair dude
hey bro get me some of that stuff what
is it I get you a wig oh man what age do
you think hopefully by that drives me
crazy my mother who says that just wear
a wig I'm with your mom what do you mean
you're with my mom
it's a [ __ ] wig duty Martinez I don't
give a [ __ ] what am I going to walk
with a wig nobelium steam aren't gonna
see that they did I have a weak Brian
Urlacher does better than Brian
that's the worst he looked great bald I
don't want to talk about it hold on
let's see this hold on what are we let's
help you what we're watching this is the
hotel he is the f-word hey not said that
is there for these days that's just
that's just guys man it's so crazy like
they just did the street comes out in
Marvel's from where Miami originally you
know huben he's used the original Kimbo
Slice
he was backyard fighting with Kimbo you
see some of those videos it's definitely
not afraid of Bisbing they're very
similar in size Mazda ball walked around
about 190 and what's what's that what
was that beef about they just don't just
watch the rock get along yeah they were
they really don't get along they never
how a classic no has nothing do with
weight classes
it's just they just well if they were
fighting each other I would understand
but that that's just out of nowhere it's
like what do you know there's there's
been a long history of those two okay I
mean I I picked cowboy to beat Mazda on
Mazda attacked me on social media he's
very aware when people say something
about him I'm a huge amount also sense
I love I love watching fight
I thought he posted the video guess not
he would not post the video that's not
his style at all no that's why he's
making fun of his bingo and you live for
this you want this video like this what
you do
that's not Mazel Tov style at all gotcha
he's a pure straight fighter I mean
goddamn his name - purebred for god
sakes all right cool
what so we have to talk about Tyrese
crazy no dude there's two different
things though he had posted on strange
cat he posted on Instagram and Facebook
so the Instagram one was like saying he
would leave the fast and furious nine if
the way in the rock Johnson is in it
when my face no no please no no please
don't leave that's just a teen and
people are making fun about that
obviously so this would put super Tyrese
put Tyrese hello world hello loyal fans
and loved ones from our fast hours I'm
sorry to announced that if Dwayne is in
Fast 9 the role there well no more Roman
Pearce which is his character you mess
with the family and my daughter survival
I mess with yours
close your eyes dude you're a clown
hashtag candy-ass [ __ ] made all my real
one men on integrity my real ones out
here stand up folks that GP to the gym
and get big naturally hashtag no juice
hashtag no oj spin off huh swing off
these nuts selfish champ pause notice
who's got his arms around my shoulder
and who stand alone hashtag our children
matter it's really bizarre he sounds
like a jealous Act or some [ __ ] just to
the rocks killing things like dude I
don't have time to do fast and furious
19 or the [ __ ] you isn't very I'm doing
all this other stuff is it Cudi gonna
have a spinoff without us man we're
family rocks like what [ __ ] imma whadda
ya I don't even know what to say about
that I don't even know what this is what
else did he put so he's got your product
of Hollywood he went on his Facebook and
then he recorded this video where he's
actually crying and talking about being
broke not being able to see his
daughters meltdown
he's having a huge meltdown I mean and
he cries that I'm crying this is
Facebook but she's also an actor so
let's see this it's a super long video
but I'll show you some hold up be I'm
saying this to all the fathers you know
compassion is being able to understand
the seat and the reality someone else is
sitting in that's compassion it's not
about the seat that you're sitting in
the rock it's about the seat that
everybody's sitting in you know that's
his daughter Shayla my first and only
pregnancy to this day he said there's
another one on the way but yeah he is a
he has got a Messiah Complex boy and he
is such a narcissist it's incredible I'm
not gonna sit here and paint the picture
of systemic racism I'm just gonna say
though you know our fathers has made it
bad for the involve fathers because our
voices are someway somehow being drowned
out when the real fathers show up when
the real fathers that really love their
kids are really a standing what the
babies are there because they're in the
presence of so many fathers what the
[ __ ] is he talking about
exactly what is he talking about Moses
he's taking real fathers taking this to
some large like this social media
audience and the rock is like what and
I'm busy I am you know how busy I am
yeah what are we supposed to do that's
the 18 proud to have you see the rock
schedule yes schedule his 80 featured
films in the next two years
it's crazy Christians the men that wake
up every day goes on and then you just
so I guess it breaks that's sweatshirts
awful buy you're likely to go so this is
this kind of sad because although he
playing a camera
is he losing this kid in court or
something yeah so far why that's why for
alleges that he abusive his daughter he
hit his daughter that's what she's
alleging and he has like a restraining
order against him right now the camera
the rocks baby mama no this is a rock
puppet mr. rock before the rock clown
them goes your CD [ __ ] yeah can I see
that yes a little how much is this just
a little quick shout-out to Tyrese his
new album black rose I just heard it I
literally just heard it I heard the
whole thing in my trailer and I've got
to say in all honesty it's the biggest
piece of duck that I have ever heard
everyone's laughing by the way but it's
true cuz everybody's heard it too
everyone heard it right there look at
all everyone's like yeah big piece of
duck should they call Black Rose should
be called big piece of black dog that's
what it called not even a hard dried-up
dog for seven days it's too soft doc
don't go out the Rob a rich chrome was
like and I never want to hear it again
and I'm never gonna forgive him for
wasting my time that is time I will
never get back like duck is in my ear
mother as a rock band
I almost wish he didn't do that it's
kind of funny though but yeah he
patterns but I feel like he's bigger
than that I really like like yeah he's
only one like let Tyreese go on this
whatever he's doing if the rock he just
shouldn't even acknowledge it yeah that
was before the when Tyra is saying like
he's breaking up the family during those
days I know I know I don't think he'll
say anything cuz notorious thing is like
it's getting real it's sad there's a
meltdown I hope he's all right but if he
so there's a allegedly he domestic
violence towards his kid yep so I ever
hear the initial court documents said
that he was abusing his daughter by
pushing her to the ground pinning her
face down putting his knees to her back
grabbed her hands with one arm beat her
with the other and he allegedly hit her
between 12 and 16 times and then she's
saying right now with all the videos
coming out that you can see that there's
something wrong with him he had
she says that he has bipolar and manic
behavior disorder
and it was diagnosed by three cycles
that's what it feels like to me and I'm
not I don't know [ __ ] about that it
seems like it's very your behavior when
you're when you're crying on camera for
all of us as a grown man that's very
strange behavior honestly I mean bipolar
or not if he did that the kid I'd like
to do that to him I mean yeah [ __ ] what
your mental condition is yeah I don't
know if if that's real but if he did
that then that's absolutely hopefully
figure [ __ ] out yeah I mean by the way
though I kind of get like like that
doesn't he doesn't seem she doesn't
strike me as very stable I don't think
he's I understand if the court took him
away took her away courts take that [ __ ]
really seriously they look yeah it's not
like him just make accusations be some
evidence yeah yeah and oh that's what
they side with you've got three if this
is true that we're reading I don't know
but if you've got three psychotherapists
who are saying he's got bipolar disorder
and man you know come on man that's
that's not the safest thing they have
around a kid so I mean it's a bummer but
I get it I don't know hope fast and
furious none myself yeah I mean oh by
the way that whole rant is not even
making sense
he's not even completing sentences he's
forgetting words I've been how though
yeah it could be a lot of things jugs
yeah some yeah crying he's crying he's
saying that his ex-wife that's took the
daughter away she's the one that said he
abused her so that's why he's losing
movie roles that's why he can't make
money and he's he's like also like
paying her thirteen thousand a month so
that's one of the reasons why he hates
the rock for postponing though oh god
it's the muddy because he needs money
not the rocks fault I know don't push
that sounds like a you problem he's just
he's just hitting like the low of lows
right now finances jumpin exercise
franchise yeah I've never really yeah
that's a bummer sucks
yeah seems like a sweet man at the end
of the day I'm a fan I like him just
[ __ ] I never saw any of those movies I
saw one clip of him and he was
actually funny he was fun fast as yours
yeah he plays like a womanizer kind of
guy I saw him in the first slot he was
funny into what I saw he was actually
quite funny got a sense of humor but
sounds like the first fast fierce and
that's on that movie four brothers which
is good with Mark Wahlberg that is good
anything he's good Holly is talented
there's a reason why the guy keeps
getting work yeah yes that's not a
mistake
he's always counting mm-hmm what else
you got you all right so the mile-high
club
two strangers never met sat next to each
other and they had sex but oral sex so
she was giving him a [ __ ] but they
didn't go in the bathroom they did it at
their seats so the woman 48 48 and the
guy's 28 old old old gray bird sucked
what she's only two years younger than
me that's hot but it could be felony
charges they could face yeah for a
[ __ ] some flight peanuts and a dick
sighs all that stuff that goes yeah
charges indecent exposure or sex now for
some my honey roasted nuts and a dick
suck on a flight from Detroit to hell it
does those you know bathrooms are tiny
there's Tim they're in their seats I've
done it so dick on a flight I've had my
dick sucked well know what talk about
sucking dick and I've ended up take out
of flight and I've played around and
I've had tried to have sex in a [ __ ]
bathroom but it didn't quite work out in
a plane bathroom so I'm part of the
mile-high club and above both cases
women I'd kind of just met there
I bet I didn't touch that me two met
there for about two hours
me too but with this thing I would I
would be annoyed if I was on a flight
and some girls just
swabbing away at the homeboys dick next
to me
okay sure hey that would be we're trying
to have a fun one girl I know one girl
and I'm seeing a little bit afterwards
it's great man yeah yeah yeah but this
ain't cool no or huh well it ain't cool
you could say it's not cool
you could just say it's really hot I'd
have to see I'd hate to be shitty I
gotta see you the 48 year old looks like
does that be on a flavor like whoops
what's this people are so people are sex
so in order the salami people do crazy
[ __ ]
not really sure they do nah I mean
sucking dick in the open on a flight
gonna be a real kind of [ __ ] this guy I
know how can I tell this story never
mind what anyway good story bro yeah
well there's this this guy no works in
an office with these with a bunch of
people and there's a super meek woman
who is like let's just say she's a daddy
at data entry person so in the movie you
know the girls got the glasses and she's
everything I guess I can do it the mousy
type and then there's this big strapping
dick who happens to be in a form of law
enforcement okay and he's just a [ __ ]
bi so apparently he turned his phone in
to my friends he turned his phone
because he was getting a new phone but
the phone is government-issued and they
so I guess they have to like I don't
know what it is well yeah are they they
clear they ya somethin they clear it is
the user and they just saw all these
[ __ ] texts between the two of them
and it's just the nastiest [ __ ] and then
he I guess I think he retired or
something and now they work with her and
everybody in the office she doesn't know
but everybody else in the office knows
she's gonna I know she's up and then
he's like guy every time I like ask her
to do something it's like she's a total
freak but you would never [ __ ] know
it like the dirtiest [ __ ] on the planet
I want you to spit in my mouth
I want you to punch me in the butt you
know all guys are crazy it's crazy saucy
girl likes to get nasty girl get in
everyone knows in the office though yep
stink I want I want you you know when
you stuck that around my ass taking you
know all this stuff crazy dirty [ __ ]
won't you to tase me and [ __ ] my mouth
yeah there's all kinds of - the way done
so depends on both ends my buddy was
like this guy had a mustache she was a
strap and Nick and he likes things in
his rump there's a whole situation
she's real freak yeah a real freak have
no I know buddy she has no idea but the
obviously the entire office knows and
she's my girl yeah but you know not poor
girl because she doesn't have any she
doesn't suspect it no she does know
they're all really quiet about it
they're all really quiet about it
hilarious can you can you can get you
want me to put this data into them yeah
I want you to put this data into the
computer a wink wink wink wink wink wink
careful sitting on that buddy errs wink
wink
dang yeah freaky oh yeah freaky freak
you never know do you
uh-uh whole slew of ass plane I mean
really dirty both of them for both of
your old topper likes it as a romper
that's what the topper like tonight
Robert my buddy ah he was like man likes
them you know he likes gives us his he
likes having his uh his starfish opened
up a little bit you know held with Oh
metal dwith gunmetal within the starfish
top likes to put the legs up in the old
air I've never been a huge ass play I
don't I've never wanted the starfish
like I've been there but for the most
part I'm happy with the other areas do
you know I'm saying like some people
that's their go-to which is that's
alright oh you're saying if you're going
on the girl don't leave Senate girl gone
you oh we've had that if we've got that
but it's their go-to it's kind of
disturbing yeah yeah the go twos your my
ass yes just reaches around gang hey
wait a minute I've on in there girl dab
on in
certified are you are you old enough yet
you guys aren't even old enough yet to
have doctors when the doctor sticks his
fingers up that room yeah bride told you
I've had that man we've got a check
around three thick Jewish fingers deep
in [ __ ]
why you got to be religious about it bro
he was Jewish okay put his three sausage
fingers in my [ __ ]
I think you told me for that wine over
there young I don't know I was good to
go there an athlete he had to check your
prostate make sense it don't make sense
mmm why don't you get chin speaking
offices in Japan there's one firm that's
gonna you know if you've ever worked in
an office have you guys worked in an
office or in corporate
you check no I hope you have three years
you know like one loophole people do if
they smoke they can always go out and
have a break in smoke everywhere still
still in 2017 well my last job they were
doing it so vape pen son 2016 yeah maybe
pen you can't do vape pens inside though
but anyways there's a Japanese company
that says for the people that don't
smoke they're giving them six additional
days off paid vacation because all the
time that they there's actually what
worked in Japan by the way huh lot of
smoke in Japan Japan they still do it
yeah still a lot some very strange
without smoke say good we don't see it
anymore Chapelle smoking vape last night
went I would said you know it's terrible
for us no my doctor says Ben cigarettes
on it I've heard different it is not
good for you a lot of chemicals use well
my doctor sound like you doctor be full
of [ __ ] yeah I know cigarettes are awful
for you as a bunch of [ __ ] and I heard
vapes not that great value I had a like
they're trying to mark it as it being
good to the Millennials and younger
audience but you know we're guinea pigs
we don't we don't really know the doctor
I talk to doctors dude thank you
it's like you know you can we could
check you for other cancers you checked
like other things you guys bladder
cancer herself but that bladder cancer
and so many those cancers only affect
for the most part smokers like so many
weird cancers not even lung cancer a lot
of other cancers come with smoking a lot
well you're just so bad for yeah you get
all kinds of weird [ __ ] stories
interesting people have smoke this day
and age like back in the day I get it we
really didn't know but it's like [ __ ]
man well now you know just know you're
just riding cushions yeah have you ever
tried it I did I tried to back on I
guess so since to in college I was threw
up at my own party and passed out in
college this it's kid Eric he was like
up from Jersey just a big [ __ ] stud
rough guy put work construction
he's in college and he was just like a
rough kid and a great guy and and and he
was live like just a man and I was like
geez this guy's a [ __ ] bad he smoked
he would smoke Marlboro just light up
too and the way he did it was like the
Marlboro Man and one day we were walking
and he opens cigarette he goes you won't
want I go yeah I was like I think I'll
start smoke
just once in a while to be a man [ __ ]
couldn't even inhale it even when I
smoke weed I took it I did a nicotine
patch and it made me so sick my buddy
had it he was like oh it's fun to do I
kept throwing up I've done nicotine
patches I eat the nicorette gum I get so
sick from nicotine I chew tobacco for a
while makes me feel so sick and I went
through a very short period of time
where I was smoking cigars cigars same
thing you get out you get like dizzy why
and then you get I just couldn't take it
man yeah I like marijuana but nicotine
not my not my bag baby
yeah what else get chin chin you look
like a smoker do i I've tried it before
yeah and it does give you a buzz you
don't like you need that stuff you have
no vices now that stuff no vices if
anything just drinking beer just killing
people we're in the skin yeah MJ you
have no vices anything beside some type
what do some know I smoke weed sometimes
I like edibles I'm like they'll probably
like edible I can like [ __ ] with edibles
any day that's so strange most people go
away from edibles less you're Joey Diaz
yeah like after like some surgeries I've
had and whatnot like my face I couldn't
smoke so I would eat edibles like up to
500 milligrams a day Jesus Christ that's
a shitty I don't like edibles cuz
there's no really like there's no
there's no measurement
yeah there's no exact science than how
much you're eating so you can get the
most kind of tested but kind of yeah
it's still kind of in the air it's not
really regulated I love instead of a
vape pen vape pens always break on me
they're always like unreliable and a
leak you can't leave them in the heat
because then it ruins the cartridge and
interesting yeah so you know I have a
vape pen that my boy jino from speed
weed gave me when I do comedy now he
always does Sam Tripoli shows yeah how
many chaos it's sponsored by speed weed
and
so there's these big boxes of everything
edibles bait pens but there's a vape
thing in there that has melatonin in it
for sleeping oh it's nice Wow one hit of
that I am out out
it's glorious those creams are really
nice - you're good - yeah inside just
like rub it on it felt so nice CBD
creams have you any injuries oh you need
it because you have these guys those
will help for sure so good I never took
yeah it's better than painkillers eating
that stuff the CBD lotion I have some
photos you want it what would you do
amazing no it helps with inflammation
and pain and it's really really good for
you too yeah yeah yeah we don't have any
places doing I'm gonna do weed at night
other than I just don't I mean I can
party in about a week I just bought a
bottle I had some Japanese whiskey I
bought some good Japanese whiskey your
house obsessed with it in my green rooms
now you know I only demand that you have
his coffee now I asked for Campari some
do it some don't yeah Campari
I got some very good sake I got some
Jack employs the crib I got some very
good sipping tequila yeah I'm becoming
quite the spirit of wine wine is tough
for me man oh you think you do it yeah
it's an older wine it's good shame
yeah used to be the wine oh I know I
know but I'll tell you this right now
maybe a spoiler alert November 11th
fight companion with Rogan he's gonna
cook some meat I'm gonna bring some
stupid wine like I brought good wine I'm
bringing stupid I won't be there what do
you mean I'm in Nashville god damn it
I know Rogan asked yesterday campaign in
11th I went I'm in Nashville for the
full weekend we're gonna cook somebody
Saturday might get a workout in because
he's got a gym then we're cook some meat
some game meat then I'm gonna open up
once again stupid wines
what you're gonna do that oh my god be
there be it killed me I know I'll be you
Edinburgh and Rogan cool guys talk zero
fighting or what is yet to write you
don't drink beer I don't I drink beer or
when I
there's nothing else cuz I'm thirsty but
now I'm not a beer I had to last night
because Chappelle was drinking uh Africa
the [ __ ] it was called a beer though the
beer stressed for the end maybe brother
Oggy Negra Modelo maybe I wasn't gonna
have whatever he's having then I was
just thirsty I didn't want the Bears
just thirst do you ever have that yeah
it's like cold beer sometimes a cold
beer is a good thing so I had two of
those yeah actually play golf or
something in that in the Sun you sit
down yeah I'm not a big beer that's so
fulfilling it's a little filling that's
the good that's what I like about it
though cuz when you drink wine er or
even like cocktails you get drunk fast
so beer you kind of take your time sip
in it and then you see a slow steady
buzz I'm kind of obsessed with I'm
obsessed now with like sorry it's like
Japanese wine I'm gonna freakin Japanese
whiskey the reason I like Japanese
whiskey is because they they're know
like filter it through coffee and they
do all kinds of weird [ __ ] but it makes
it's so smooth like I like if I know
about how they make it like some sake
they like place they polish the rice
until it's 50 percent its size it's
always we're like what they it goes
through 50 cloths and you're like oh and
then sometimes you can I get on maybe
that's what I'm drinking maybe I'm like
whoo I like the amount of craftsmanship
that goes into it the story yeah the
story
what else you got gin alright have you
ever like not like something for a long
time and then you start into it that
Betsy that's what whiskey and tequila
are like for me I never used to be into
it and now I'm now I've become a refined
I'm a refined gentleman I'd never drank
alcohol ever until that Campari but yeah
partying and [ __ ] the two things that
you know in Elgin right but uh uh why
not try and be a bully but if you bring
up Japanese whiskey on one more podcast
yeah I'm seeing us for all the listeners
yeah we're gonna be job why do I say
word means I'm gonna be jumping yeah
just use your them you can't just bully
me like for them you're using your sizes
oh no no that's then that's no but
you're using the robot they're probably
like don't
Brannen I'm the robot nobody you don't
know how they're thinking I do you have
your urea on them yes you're just gonna
start batting me about yes are you gonna
bat me about you wish like where around
my hips you wish once you hold me down
with Kevin well that's good all right so
a girl whatever a girl who had a
roommate at her college at Hartford
University she didn't like her and so
she did all this stuff to make her leave
like including using rubbing her used
tampons on her backpack and a bunch of
his stuff so let's see here what do you
her toothbrush in places where the Sun
don't shine like up her [ __ ] yeah
that's what's supposed I've done that
well also and then she she put like she
spit into her something that she drinks
her eats and then she put clam stuff
inside her lotions she's kind of [ __ ]
up in the head cuz when he spent
someone's drink you get the pleasure but
they really don't know so it's you're
kind of [ __ ] up we knew that but also
if you just show me a picture I can
usually tell you if they're guilty or
not she put movi go ahead and bring that
girl up cuz she look anymore like buzz
from [ __ ] home alone the bully
brother was his girlfriend wolf that's
what she looks like look at that [ __ ]
yeah of course a [ __ ] of course she'd
well a better picture she still looks
like a bull she doesn't look dead behind
the eyes I'll tell you that much she
looks like the girl that will take
someone's toothbrush and stick it up her
ass she bag trash on that day though she
was she bad Chuck later saying she that
she wrote that on Instagram to make it
sound more funny but she does say that
she admits rubbing her used tampon on
that girl's back that's the most
disturbing thing I'd rather yeah I can
put that to my teeth I mean also also
like also to make your tampon in my
backpack who like I don't know it's like
I heard she's getting charged with a
hate crimes here Jesus because she said
Jamaican Barbie yeah
oh come on [ __ ] off oh no no cuz maybe
she doesn't like her she try to make her
move out because she was black like
there could be underlying reasons why
she wanted her out okay a kidnap victim
in Alabama and there's videotape
you did I haven't seen this keep going
some guys some guy broke into this
girl's house singing up yeah someone
broke into this girl's house choked her
asked for money and then stuck him stuck
her in his trunk and then when he went
to the gas station you know there's a
little lever in trunks
yeah hopped up and runs up and ran off
so this is the video it was that a
Saturn anything around terrifying this
is not a Saturn think about this so
that's the dude walking out and then he
walks calmly wait Pops's burster that
sheep trust open and she's hauling ass
into this you woke her why did she run
the same light she run the same way with
his door it's panic so then he's walking
nonchalantly to the cash register in a
powerful sweater and then you could see
her pop in it's an evil human being
right there very evil but evil look and
then what happened watch you'll see
you're popping right here so she pops in
runs inside he notices so he books it
out oh [ __ ] he leaves right away to his
car I caught did they catch him yeah
please do I shake this up he runs he
slams his trunk boom and then he takes
off yeah they caught him and apparently
he was on bond for a check out his rap
sheet
that's him by the way nice again show me
his picture I probably tell you with
guilty enough yeah it is it so on bond
for attempted murder sodomy in the first
degree and robbery in the third degree
all right what's he going on out on the
streets for Oh crazy right attempted
murder a but he had bond Jesus be
praised [ __ ] jail good kill that guy
shitty but I can kill him I agree I
agree what are you doing what do you
need him around first see are you
breaking the woman's house to strangle
him and put them in your trunk and out
of that awful Charlie Brown sweatshirt I
can kill that guy there's something
wrong with him there's something wrong
with those people what else you got Jim
this one is on Barstow sports so the CIA
CIA released documents showing what bin
Laden actually watched
Natasha is hiding and they are hilarious
yeah his hobbies what is it so one of
this is video of crocheting by Theresa
check out this list here he was born
is this you know the charlie bit my
finger video yeah a little too babies he
was watching that wow this one kids are
grown mr. bean what yes
here's a list of all the stuff there's
like little celebrity things where it's
like they're just like us
he watched ants cars Chicken Little
CNN presents world's most wanted he was
like hell yeah check this out kids uh
home on the range ice age he's obviously
watching that with all his kids or
they'd have kids there yes yeah ton of
kids Resident Evil The Three Musketeers
where in the world is if sama bin Laden
he's what's all the [ __ ] world's worst
venom Peru civilization resident evil
storm rider clash of the evils the
Kremlin from inside story of India the
three musketeers and where in the world
is Osama bin Laden cars hilarious inside
the Green Berets for I watch out like
Bach mmm-hmm what a sketch in you know
Under Armour's doing really bad right
now yeah I didn't know that you didn't
know their sales are going down they
have all these huge like athletes and
stars you know sure they're sponsored
but nothing's working so there's an ox
yeah Kevin Durant came out was like who
the [ __ ] once we're under armor no one's
gonna wear under arm yes Steph Curry
their shoes his shoes have been awful
displace much alike Canelo Anton Joshua
baby I know the owner of the company was
on the board for Trump and then he
defended Trump then Steph Curry goes
well he's defending Trump I'm out and
then he backed off then week it was
announced off the board of Trump's
campaign yeah there's a whole rock was
pissed off about that too oh yeah all
the celebrities and athletes went cold
up you're with Trump we're [ __ ] out
I'm not I'm not I'm off so what's going
on now so it says yeah it's just hard
for people to feel there's no loyalty
among the customers and it's not good
with women apparently it's not
resonating with women it's rated ice
Brian for sure female driven brain under
they make great stuff they've been
around for a while they make really good
stuff and they're higher price than like
Nike and Adidas I didn't know that yeah
they made some good stuff in there you
know they're in the MLB there
10 all over so this week on Tuesday
their stock dropped 19% starts with that
owner man where you know you can smell
there's just no transparency there like
you can tell he's fate like he was on
this Trump born he defended Trump and
then when Steph Curry goes you're a
[ __ ] he's like you're riot yeah let's
not do that
be my guy you're fake man it's too
competitive with Nike and all these
other brands adidas hmm yeah you can't
make them more expensive than Nike and
Adidas cuz they're dudes
there's nothing I equate them in my mind
the exact same product or lower yeah I
mean it says so men's running shoes for
example strut $75 at Under Armour $65
that adidas $60 for Nike I mix now for
Adidas premium shoe you look at $170
Nike huh
almost $200 yeah so when it comes to
that stuff they're still cheaper but
they said that's always been their model
like the like higher price stuff so
that's that was that working free when
you have Steph Curry's dad shoes and no
one wants to buy them mmm she said
they're promised they're not hip they're
not cool it's not cool to be an Under
Armour yeah that's the biggest thing yes
sir they said they're the ones that
started that model of the $25 t-shirts I
didn't know that we invented the 20
followers shirt uh I guess you were
[ __ ] no fair did that hmm yeah I
don't know they're in trouble there's
not hip and the thing is you really
can't become him what if they dropped
under there's just armor it's just not
that just armor what steroid ooh I don't
know I don't know man
they better figure it out though what
else you got
I think that's it feel like we've been
going long today long time it's pretty
long I gotta do I got a drop in
knowledge for us what do you think is
the most difficult one of the most
difficult animals to observe in the wild
and it's it's completely in the open you
can come right up to it it's not because
it's hidden it's tough to observe really
tough to observe really tough to observe
tough to study you can walk up some
funny yeah you can you can basically
drive up really close to them but why
it's so difficult they made ideal what
region Africa and they're just difficult
to observe because of lions can sleep so
much no technically their camouflage
zebras zebras why because as you're
studying zebras and you look down at
your a notepad you then like you're like
wait woodsy but I like it because when
they're in a group and their herd they
tend to all look the same right so you
can't resist their camouflage their
animals can't single them out because
the camouflage
now here's then then they came up with a
good idea we'll just tagged red line on
one of them or behind their ear what do
you think the problem with that was that
one hid know what he got killed by
because the line was like hold up look
you know that one has a red line on them
they died right away oh we killing
sizzler they killed him right alive he's
like get the one with the [ __ ] red
meat over the red the lines like why the
[ __ ] do they all like the [ __ ] is that
well you're the one with the red and
human beings so human beings so that
that's an evolutionary thing where you
tend to you know you want to look kind
of all the same when you're in a herd
human being social science about do
something similar with language so when
you see like everybody start using the
same language a Boston accent Lily right
yes yes that's how accents very much so
accents actually happened more because
what we do is we emulate people we look
up to correct and so somebody but this
is a little bit different so when
there's a movement an idea when people
start talking with sexism racism
homophobia which was never always the
conversation or if they start talking
about whatever it might be gender parity
is what you'll find that there are
communities that speak in all the same
language they grouped together and they
speak the same language because it's a
way of not standing out because if you
stand out and speak in a different way
you become a target
so for yeah so it becomes exactly so it
becomes very common for groups to start
using the same language because they
don't want to stand out take a look at
that and pay attention that in your own
circles to see where that is because
that's not always a good thing because
what happens is if everybody starts
talking the same language and you stay
you're saying your own echo chamber
you'll start thinking that that's the
only representation of reality and that
is a surefire way to become very
narrow-minded so that's something I've
learned after 50 [ __ ] years and I see
it worse than ever today in both the
left-wing circles and the right-wing
circles I see it everywhere we are human
it's what we do boom be different or at
least at least listen to the other side
so that you can get closer to the truth
the truth which we're all looking for
Brian I'm glad you brought that I'm glad
you put that stuff in your hair thanks
brother I want to thank you oh she's
wear a wig for us
don't say that cuz I'm gonna be used
let's get closer the truth what is that
stuff again
dragon oil Moroccan oil Moroccan oil
dragon oil and it doesn't make your hair
dirty or weird existence off mine it
probably make it flat and sit there it's
just not for you man hey you know what I
want to say this before we leave
[ __ ] your hair that's cool man yeah yeah
[ __ ] your I'd be upset too if I were you
I am upset I'll admit I'm a little
jealous
stop looking at my head dude I don't
like it don't you figure it up Brian
where you gonna be New York City Gotham
comedy club November 17th and 18th and
don't kid yourself because right after
that I'm at wise guys in Utah Salt Lake
City get your goddamn tickets at t f--
at kake.com and if you're in the San
Francisco area
December 7th 8th and 9th at Cobbs you
better come out see me there cuz I'm
bringing [ __ ] heat and I don't want to
hear about what I already saw him last
year everything I'm doing it I mean it
is completely different I've been
writing like a [ __ ] never been
more prompted by so unless you're
hopefully people would say that yeah
well you know people a lot of lot of
comments come back with the same bag of
tricks not the kid it's a come see me
where are you gonna be tomorrow I know
I'm occlusive Lucy now and I'm bringing
a beast with me to open up hey Suz Trejo
oh maybe saw him on The Late Late Night
show he's all over he's a monster at the
Comedy Store
he's coming with me Colusa casino
tomorrow night Friday night plus a
casino and then next week I kick it off
I'm in Charlotte whoo
Thursday night Charlotte Thursday night
Friday Saturday's Amy's in Nashville and
then Sunday night I'm in Columbus Ohio
so I'm going Charlotte Nashville Friday
Saturday night Sunday night I end in
Columbus Ohio all those shows are almost
sold out some are sold out gotee fat
cake calm right now get Joe ticket
ticket for myself and Brian this is the
fired kid we're out